Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wie geht's dir ganz
entspannt
ja ganz entspannt ich habe gerade den
vierten Band der Philosophie Geschichte
fertig
jeder Anmerkung ist überprüft und so
weiter das ist ein schönes Gefühl das
heißt das Ding ist jetzt wirklich fertig
und damit aus dem Kopf ja es gibt noch
meine professionelle natürlich die dann
angeht und dann redet man nachher noch
mal drüber aber es ist also ich würde
mal sagen in zwei drei Wochen aus dem
Kopf war ich ich habe gerade dieser Tage
mit Helene bubowski die du glaube ich
auch kennst
parlamentskorrespondentin der FAZ war
bei uns in der Sendung die hat ein Buch
gemacht über über den Umgang von
Politiker mit Fehlern und sie sagte nach
der seinen boah ich bin so fertig ich
kann nicht mehr also die Produktion das
Schreiben eines Buches es ist ein
unfassbar anstrengender Vorgang und wir
haben darüber gerätselt mal wieder warum
man das eigentlich macht ja weil die
aller meisten Menschen Autoren deswegen
erwähne ich sie auch immer und und
empfehle oft Bücher und so weiter
verdienen ja kaum was mit den Büchern
also warum macht man es dennoch also die
Philosophiegeschichte mache ich in
allererster Linie für mich selbst weil
das ist so unbeschäftigung
35 Jahren und das alles mal für sich so
in eine Ordnung zu bringen und
aufzuräumen es gibt ja die die Lust des
Aufräumens ja wann wann kommt die ja bei
mir nicht so oft ne also ist also die
Leute die viel aufräumen die machen das
ja nicht aufgrund der Lust des Aufpreis
sondern die machen das aus einer
automatisierten Routine heraus die
irgendwo zwischen Freiwilligkeit und
zwang liegt Zwang aber besser zum
Beispiel auch immer mache wenn ich ein
Buch fertig habe ne hier in der
kriminade stapeln sich ja die Bücher
dann werden und vor mir sind jetzt
lauter sortiert auf dann wird diese
ganze Literatur was in der vergangenen
Bücher das wird dann alles geordnet und
aufgeräumt und so und das gleiche mache
ich ja quasi beim Schreiben ich räume
also quasi meine eigenen Gedanken
in diesem Fall jetzt hier zur
Philosophie der Moderne halt auch nach
und nach auf und nachher hat man das
Gefühl so wie beim Aufräumen auch jetzt
ist alles ganz hübsch ordentlich und so
dargestellt und erklärt und so wie es
sein muss und das ist sehr lustvoll aber
in diese Bücher also die
Philosophiegeschichte innerhalb wohl die
Bände alle über 500 Seiten haben ich
glaube das ist noch mal sehr viel mehr
Arbeit als Bücher die die meisten
Journalisten schreiben ich glaube das
kann man gar nicht vergleichen also der
Stoff der hier gewesen ist der ist enorm
zwei Fragen habe ich noch ganz kurz an
Dich erste Frage gibt es einen Satz oder
vielleicht sogar den einstiegssatz auf
den du besonders stolz bist aber ist der
ist der gelungen hat der gut
funktioniert
ja also der dies ist nicht der erste
Satz nein das beginnt mit der Pariser
Weltausstellung von 1900 und das wird
erst mal so schön beschrieben damit man
so reingesaugt wird aber die Einleitung
also das war beim dritten Band der
Philosophie Geschichte so und dass ich
jetzt auch beim vierten die Einleitung
ist ja versucht diese gesamte
komplizierte schwierige Philosophie der
Moderne Heidegger und Wittgenstein und
White hat und wer so und soll Sigmund
Freud und so weiter dass alles so auf
zehn Seiten ganz ganz übersichtlich noch
mal zusammen zu fassen und das ist so
das wo ich denke das ist so die größte
Leistung dass du hinzukriegen dass man
denkt so oft zehn Seiten hat man dann
wirklich so diesen diesen Überblick noch
mal über die 500 Seiten gegeben und da
bin ich dann immer sehr stolz drauf das
war beim dritten Band auch so also es
ist 19 Jahrhundert zusammenzufassen eine
Frage habe ich noch an Dich gibt es den
einen Philosophen den einen
revolutionären Gedanken wenn du sagst
boah das ist echt gut kannte ich zwar
schon aber jetzt noch darüber
nachgedacht hat mich richtig gekriegt
passt so gut in die Zeit ja also es gibt
natürlich die Philosophen die ja näher
sind und weniger nahe sind und ich weiß
nicht ob es in diese Zeit passt ne aber
bergsong ist eigentlich so an den
deutschen Universitäten nie so ein
großes Thema und wenn man sie überlegt
dass er zu seiner Zeit der berühmteste
Philosoph Europas war und dass der
Kerngedanke von berghorn darin besteht
dass wir mit den Mitteln der
Rationalität nie begreifen werden was
Leben ist den finde ich bis heute
hochgradig spannend ja ist auch ein
romantischer Gedanke ne ja ist es wir
haben eine begriffsmaschine im Kopf und
damit versuchen wir uns alles zu
erklären Zeit und Raum und versuchen die
Dinge logisch zu begreifen und empirisch
zu erforschen und so weiter aber er sagt
das sind ja alles Hilfsmittel
ja und alles was wir auf die Art und
Weise zu Tage fördern sind am Ende
Konstruktionen aber was wirklich leben
ist das spürt man im Zweifelsfall wenn
man an einem Sommertag in einem Garten
sitzt ja oder vielleicht bei dir auf
deinen polarreisen oder so und das sind
Dinge die lassen sich gar nicht in Worte
ja richtig ja es gibt sozusagen eine
eigentliche Sphäre des da seins die man
nur erspüren kann die man aber nicht
begreifen kann und ich finde das ist ein
zeitlos großer Gedanke wie heißen
schöner Gedanke und und ich finde er
passt super in die Zeit also gerade in
einer Zeit in der wir Cookies Social
Media an was wir alles versuchen
abzubilden hier beim Verzehren ist jeden
Schnitzels sind wir dabei aber wieder
Schnitzel riecht und was ein Schnitzel
wirklich ist da hat er doch recht das
kann man nur erfüllen das kann man nicht
wirklich fotografieren und auch nicht
beschreiben je weiter die Zivilisation
fortschreitet umso mehr kommen wir in
eine Kultur der Uneigentlichkeit
na wie entfernen uns über den
technischen Fortschritt und dessen
kulturelle Folgen immer mehr von unseren
natürlichen Intuitionen ich glaube das
ist der Motor des technischen
Fortschritts ist die Bequemlichkeit
es ist also ein zweiter Linie vielleicht
noch der Wohlstand aber in erster Linie
erlaubt uns Technik immer fauler zu
werden und ich glaube aber dass dieses
immer fauler werden bei gleichzeitiger
völliger Überreiztheit durch
Informationen ein ganz ganz eigenartigen
Zustand generiert irgendwie sind wir man
sagt ja heute gäbe es weniger Sex als in
früheren Zeiten aber dafür gibt es mehr
Konsum von Sex also Pornografie und
Erotisierung von allem und so weiter und
so weiter also wir sind auch was Sex und
anders Fakt ja und das sind wir glaube
ich nicht nur in sexueller Hinsicht
sondern das sind wir auch was unser
Leben im Allgemeinen belangt ja also
überreizt und im gleichen Maße
unbefriedigt ja und daraus entsteht ja
diese diese unzuf Zufriedenheit die man
überall so spürt es ist das was du
meinst ja also ich kann es auch anders
ausdrücken weißt du wir konsumieren
heute mehr Informationen an einem Tag
also so ein durchschnittlicher Mensch in
unserer Kultur als früher irgendein
Bauer in einem Jahr und ich will nicht
sagen unsere Gehirne sind damit
überfordert aber zumindestens sind sie
latent überreizt und jetzt haben wir
noch ein Problem früher lebten die
Menschen in natürlichen Gewissheiten die
entstanden einfach dadurch wurde in ein
Milieu rein geboren und ein Kultur man
wusste nicht viel über andere Länder ja
man war entweder Bauer oder man war
Handwerker oder Kamera Kaufmanns Familie
und man war katholisch oder man war
evangelisch und man war Bayer oder
Holsteiner oder was auch immer man war
also eingebunden in ein festen
erzählungsrahmen und das hat den
Menschen Sicherheit und Identität
gegeben ja also die heute ist ja immer
so FIFA narrativen die Rede und früher
musste man sich keine narrative suchen
man wurde innovativer eingeboren ist
richtig und heute leben wir in dieser
multi-informationsgesellschaft wo man
nicht mehr weiß was man glauben soll wo
man nicht mehr weiß sind ist das eine
verlässliche Informationsquelle man wird
überflutet von Informationen und auf der
anderen Seite diese normalen Erzählungen
in die man hineingeboren sind was ein
Sicherheit und Halt gibt die spielen
eigentlich für die allermeisten Menschen
fast keine Rolle mehr da ist nur noch
ganz wenig übrig geblieben im
Zweifelsfall noch die die Liebe zu
Schalke 04 oder zum FC Bayern ja also
irgendwas was noch so eine Vater auf den
Sohn oder so übergegangen ist ja und das
heißt die die grundsätzliche unsicher
Zeit der Philosoph würde das jetzt die
transzendentale Obdachlosigkeit nennen
keinen Sitz mehr im Leben ja super das
hat enorm zugenommen
transzendentale Obdachlosigkeit
von großartig Anfang des Jahrhunderts ja
und man lebt also in dieser
transzendentalen Obdachlosigkeit ist
überreizt mit Informationen weiß nicht
was man glauben soll und parallel dazu
steigt die innere Unruhe und
Aggressivität
und das ist so ein bisschen man man hat
seine seine Seelen Heimat verloren
ja das ist wahr sind also das ist genau
das also ich ich habe das Gefühl ich
vielleicht liegt es daran dass ich vom
Land komme ja vom sogar vom Berg komme
dieses das habe ich ihn Städten immer
gespürt und dieses Gefühl der
Heimatlosigkeit das das Leute nicht so
richtig wissen
wer sie eigentlich sein wollen und auch
sein sollen und ich ich fand es immer
befremdlich dass Menschen so scheinbar
ja offenbar sind sie es ja nicht aber
scheinbar so so problemlos in der Lage
waren heute Hamburg als ihre Heimat zu
empfinden und morgen dort und übermorgen
bei München und und dann Tokio und
Singapur und so weiter das war alles so
beliebig das war alles so austauschbar
und wie war das immer sehr suspekt ja
wenn man jemand macht
eigentlich gut also da will man ja ja wo
wird wo wird der durchschnittliche
Deutsche geboren ja in einer kleinen
oder Mittelstadt
so wie ich in Solingen oder so und dass
man dann denkt wie die Bremer
Stadtmusikanten etwas besseres findet
man über alle in der Welt und wie
aufregen muss es sein in Paris in London
oder New York oder so zu sein und man
kann sich in dem Alter so ich jedenfalls
konnte mir vorstellen als ich zu Hause
auszog überall zu leben genau wenn man
wenn man älter wird ändert sich das ein
bisschen das liegt daran dass einem
plötzlich Dinge auffallen die wenn man
junges alten gar nicht auffallen oder
das aufregender lässt nach und das
nervige nimmt zu und dann ist eigentlich
diese dieser dieser heimatwunsch der
verstärkt sich mit zunehmendem Alter bei
mir ist das ein bisschen schwierig
ich habe ja keine keine richtige Heimat
weil meine Eltern nicht aus Solingen kam
ich bin jetzt nicht nur vor verwurzelter
Solinger also meine Eltern waren
zugezogen ne ich war noch kein Solinger
Platz
ich hatte keinen einzigen Verwandten
außerhalb der Familie in Solingen und
meinen Eltern haben sich in Solingen
jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig
wohlgefühlt aus einer ganzen Reihe von
Gründen mein Vater kam in Hannover hatte
der sich bewegt in so einer so eine
Avantgarde
ja also für damals zeitgenössische Kunst
was völlig verpönt war 50er Jahre ja da
war das in allen Zeit ja da waren das
Verrückte die sich dafür für
zeitgenössische Kunst interessiert haben
oder viele Literatur und da war es für
meinen Vater unglaublich schwierig in
Solingen Anschluss zu finden vorstellen
der hat überhaupt keine Gesprächspartner
oder Gleichgesinnte ihr da finden konnte
und meine Familie hatte immer so ein
Außenseiterstatus eigentlich deswegen
habe ich jetzt nicht die große Sehnsucht
nach Solingen wo ich gestern Abend noch
war mein Vater besucht habe wie alt ist
der will fragen darf der wird jetzt 90
ein schönes Alter ich habe noch nicht
ein großartiges Stück von Sebastian
Herrmann heißt der glaube ich gelesen
in der Süddeutschen Zeitungs hat einen
herrlichen Titel der Gipfel des Unglücks
ist mit 49 Jahren erreicht ah ja soll
ich total gut der darüber schreibt
sozusagen was man gewinnt wenn man älter
wird und und sagt also diese ganze
Unsicherheit der ganze dieser ganze
selbstoptimierungs waren ja dass das
steigert sich bis ungefähr zum Alter von
49 dann ist der absolute Tiefpunkt
erreicht und interessanterweise werden
Menschen dann so ab 60 wieder
zufriedener wenn Deutschland deutlich
entspannter ja das ja in zwei Jahren der
Fall ich will mal sehr gespannt ja ich
also ich muss sagen ich weiß nicht er
beschreibt das auch so schön dieses
Szene ja wie die die Gleitsichtbrille
sorgt dann dafür dass man irgendwann die
Augen vor der Wahrheit nicht mehr länger
verschließen kann ja also die die die
sozusagen dieses Gefühl du verlängerst
deine Jugend immer noch ein bisschen
mehr und ein bisschen weiter ja das ist
irgendwann ist es einfach aber man muss
beim Optiker kommt der Moment der
Wahrheit und er sagte na klar und dann
zögerst du und haderst mit diesem Moment
der Kauf der ersten Gleitsichtbrille
aber irgendwann muss es einfach sein und
dann hat man hätte man doch eigentlich
das Gefühl okay jetzt geht's endgültig
zu Ende und erstaunlich ist dass dann
aber offenbar eine Phase großer
Zufriedenheit kommt und das beobachte
ich auch bei Leuten wenngleich ich immer
sagen muss ich glaube das hängt auch
sehr für den persönlichen
Lebensumständen natürlich ab ne ja hast
du noch die Chance was zu gestalten
jemand zum Beispiel der der der
erfolgreicher tolle Autor ist bei den
Kollegen der Süddeutschen da z.B der hat
natürlich eine eine Karriere der hat
eine Perspektive der der kann das noch
ganz lange machen der hat das der hat
das drauf
wenn du aber jemand bist der mit 49 z.B
körperlich völlig am Ende ist und seinem
Beruf nicht mehr nachgehen kann oder die
Karriere hat nicht funktioniert was ist
Menschen der Fall das muss man ja mal
dazu sagen ne diejenigen werden Tor sind
ja nun die allerwenigsten und mit 49
kannst du ziemlich gut absehen ob du
noch irgendein karriereschwung noch
machen wirst und der müsste dann ganz
schnell erfolgen oder du wirst keinen
mehr machen und ich glaube das ist so
das Schwierige an dem Alter aber
sagt es gibt viele Studien darüber es
behauptet er nicht einfach so ne also
große studienaufwendige Studien die
sagen dass diese Langzeitstudien das
fortgeschrittenes Alter ja weniger
Stress weniger Sorgen weniger Ärger all
diese Dinge führen zu einer generellen
einer größeren Zufriedenheit ja und alt
zu werden geht also mit einem wachsenden
emotionalen Wohlbefinden einher so ja
findens gelingt ja richtig ich glaube
darum geht es also man muss sich mit
vielem nicht abfinden bis man 50 ist und
dann einerseits muss man sich mit dem
Alterungsprozess dann irgendwann
abfinden weil irgendwann kann man eben
auch mit der Gleitsichtbrille die Augen
nicht mehr verschließen ja vor dem
Alterungsprozess interessant das zweite
ist eben sich sich abfinden dass man
vielleicht nicht die Rolle in der Welt
spielt die man sich mal erhofft oder
erträumt hat als man jung war wie man
spielen wollte oder dass man sagt ach
eigentlich so mit 60 ne hatte ich ja gar
nicht so ein schlechtes Leben und das
gilt natürlich gerade für unsere
Generationen goldene Generation der
Bundesrepublik und wir machten uns ja
alle viel mehr Sorgen um das Leben
unserer Kinder und unserer Enkel
Klimawandel ja ähm
aggressivere Weltlage und so weiter und
denken immer wir haben wir für eine
vergleichsweise gute Zeit erlebt ja wenn
man anfängt sich selbst auf die Schulter
zu klopfen und denkt auch war ja gar
nicht so schlecht ne dann setzt dieser
zufriedenheitsprozess eben ein der einem
hilft ja die nennt das das Alter ist
Zufriedenheit Paradoxon ja weil es ist
ja eigentlich völlig widersprüchig so
längst alles wird schlecht und so weiter
oder gibt's Daten unter anderem aus
Norwegen bei Norweger sind ziemlich
zufrieden und glückliche Menschen habe
ich immer das Gefühl und die sagen da
gibt's halt diesen Trend ne also die die
der Zusammenhang zwischen Lebensalter
und subjektiven Wohlbefinden ja das ist
quasi wie eine ukurve ja so ein jungen
Jahren
fortgeschrittenes Erwachsenenalter dann
da ist alles schön und hell und
freundlich und wir machen uns auf den
Weg und so weiter und dann kommen diese
mittleren
Gleitsichtbrillen Jahre ja also die
ersten Jahre da schieben sich dann so
ein paar dunkle Wolken über den Horizont
und dann geht's wieder nach oben und der
schreibt diesen schönen Satz der Gipfel
des Unglücks liegt irgendwo zwischen 40
und 50 das Zeichen total gut dachte gut
dass ich darüber hinaus bin
erlebst du das auch so Richard bei dir
hast du das selber subjektiv so
wahrgenommen bei mir war das nicht so
weil es sich Mitte 40 war veränderte
sich mein Leben durch den Erfolg von wer
bin ich also gerade quasi in der Phase
die besonders kritisch gewesen wäre
darüber nachzudenken warum aus mir
nichts geworden ist
das hat also diese diese Unglück also
nicht ausgehen übertönt ja übertüncht
aber das kann ja bei mir dann noch mit
Mitte 60 oder so kommen vielleicht hätte
ich ja dann unzufrieden daran
er ist interessant und die schreiben das
habe ich mir auch noch gemerkt fand ich
total spannend und das kannst du auch
gerade beobachten wenn du dir was ich
denke immer noch an dieses Gespräch mit
Carla Rochel weißt du das letzte
Generation die hat mich irgendwie
wirklich gepackt und ich stimme auch
nicht in diesem Chor der Leute an die
sagen boah und jetzt muss man die muss
man jetzt Leute eingesperrt worden von
der letzten Generation völlig korrekt ja
wenn man sich daneben benimmt und gegen
Geld nicht Recht verstößt und gerade
verurteilt worden ist und dann rausgeht
und sich direkt wieder festklebt
dann muss man halt damit rechnen dass
man dann irgendwann auch in Knast geht
und trotzdem
finde ich muss man die schon auch ernst
nehmen und das berührt einen ja ich sehe
das also es ist existenzielle
ethischer Impuls und ja sie haben eine
Warnfunktion also wenn diese letzte
Generation fehlen würde dann gäbe es
immer noch hinreichend Menschen die den
Klimawandel nicht ernst genug nehmen
würden also ich glaube sie erfüllen eine
nützliche Funktion ich glaube das
wirklich und ich glaube auch dass das
ist was Sie mit diesem Pathos antreibt
und sie auch Gefängnisstrafen in Kauf
nehmen lässt ja im Sinne einer höheren
Sache einer höheren Sache dienen genau
das ist ja die grundsätzlich verkehrt
aber was was ähm dort auch beschrieben
wird das fand ich so interessant und das
hat dann auch für mich plötzlich so ein
das war wie so eine Tür die sich da
öffnet diese Altersforschung sagt die
Angst vor dem Sonnenuntergang ist ein
Phänomen der Jugend ja also gerade junge
Leute neigen sozusagen zur Apokalypse ja
aber das ist doch relativ einfach warum
das so ist als junger Mensch hast du
Angst dass die Welt untergeht als alter
Mensch das so Angst dass du untergehst
also du zählst quasi die Jahre wie lange
du noch lebst du kannst dich jetzt nicht
mehr für die ganze Welt verantwortlich
fühlen weil du siehst ja dein eigenes
Ende vor Augen und damit bist Du
natürlich viel mehr beschäftigt und wenn
jung bist dann glaubst du nicht dass
dann eigenes Leben auf natürliche Art
und Weise schnell zu Ende gehen kann und
hofft auch dass es nicht passiert mit
dem gleichen Maße fühlst du dich für die
Welt verantwortlich
was wenn man jung ist dann traut man
sich die Kraft zu die Welt zu verändern
richtig ja und wenn man alt ist ist man
froh wenn man es schafften paar kleine
eigene Gewohnheit zu verändern ist
richtig also da verändert sich natürlich
der Trichter und deswegen ist auch klar
die Zufriedenheit im Leben wächst mit
der
Verschwinden der Ansprüche an sich
selbst
weniger man noch von sich erwartet umso
leichter ist es auch mit sich und der
Welt zufrieden zu sein ja das sagen die
übrigens auch das im Alter sinken die
Ansprüche und das entspannt natürlich
ganz enorm ja was das ist schon wahr und
dann kommt es natürlich auf gewisse
Charaktereigenschaften an ne also wenn
du zum Beispiel Gewissenhaftigkeit sagen
diesen wichtiger Charakterzug der dann
auch ins Alter hinein wird weil wenn du
gewissenhaft bist dann bist du auch in
jungen Jahren eher bereit sozusagen
Freundschaften zu pflegen und zu
erhalten und im Alter wird dann diese
Freundschaft zu einem wirklich kostbaren
Schatz das interessant ja weil du als
junger Mensch schläfst du ja sehr
schnell Freundschaften in die Eltern man
wird umso mehr bekannter hast du und
umso weniger Freunde in Relationen dazu
richtig weil du dich nicht mehr mit Haut
und Haaren auf andere Menschen einlässt
und weil du vielleicht auch den Hunger
nach anderen Menschen nicht hast der ja
sehr intensiv sein muss damit eine
richtig gute Freundschaft daraus
entsteht muss ich für den anderen ja
sehr sehr interessieren sonst ist er ja
kein Freund von dir du musst sehr viel
gemeinsam erleben um eine Freundschaft
zu festigen und das sind alles Dinge da
fehlt dir dann im Alter die Zeit zu und
dann hast du auch deinen hoffentlich
jedenfalls deinen Satz von 5 6 guten
Freunden und der Rest bleibt dann
notorisch im bekannten Status er ist
wahr es war dieses das einzige was
sozusagen was was mich daran so ein
bisschen irritiert ist also der Faktor
Zeit ne ich ich habe mal Gespräch mit
Udo Jürgens vor Jahren geführt über
genau dieses Thema und er sagte ich
glaube das ist glaube ich schon mal
erzählt am Anfang des Lebens läuft
einfach Sand durch die Sanduhr deines
Lebens und dann ist es irgendwann Gold
und dann ist es Platine es wird immer
wertvoller und der der große Philosoph
hat sich Schröder er sagte mir
irgendwann mal da war so um die 50 liebe
Grüße lieber Atze sagte Markus weißt du
jetzt bin ich 50 ich bin mir darüber im
Klaren noch 20 geile Sommer
und das habe ich mir wirklich gemerkt
ich dachte ja also und Atze macht aber
keinen unzufriedenen Eindruck dabei ist
jemand der das Leben sehr versteht
deswegen mag ich ihn auch so aber
natürlich die Vorstellung dass da
sozusagen so ein Countdown läuft ja von
20 langsam runter auf Null das ist
natürlich schon etwas was einen
befremdet und wenn du dann siehst
deswegen frage ich auch gerade nach dem
Alter deines Vaters bin dann siehst wie
Menschen die dann sehr alt werden die
wollen das dann irgendwann nicht mehr
und das die Phase erlebe ich auch bei
meiner Mutter zum Teil das ist das weiß
mir Gnade also
wenn ich morgen nicht mehr aufwache ist
nicht schlimm
ich meine diesen Zustand zu erreichen ja
der spricht nichts gegen also es ist
viel Jahre wenn man wenn man klammert
und noch da bleiben will und das Gefühl
hatten noch nicht fertig zu sein mit dem
Leben also am Ende ist das ist das gut
wenn man diesen Zustand erreichen ja das
ist wahr aber ich glaube dennoch dass
die die Angst natürlich vor vor dem Tod
die ist da die hat jeder Mensch die die
die ist einfach ganz tief in uns drin
und ich weiß nicht hast du das auch
erlebt mit deinen mit deinen Kindern
wenn du also Kinder haben ja irgendwann
Phasen wo sie anfangen ganz intensiv
über die eigene Vergänglichkeit
nachzudenken das kommt ganz früh das ist
sehr interessant die werden plötzlich
wird den klar okay das ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass ich am Leben bin
und dann kommt mitunter so eine richtige
Panik vor dem Tod vor dem eigenen Ende
vor dem Sterben hoch und ich ich weiß
nicht ich habe oft gedacht wie
beantwortet man diese Frage eigentlich
gut wenn die kommt Papa muss sich jemand
sterben und ich habe dann irgendwann
gesagt weißt du wenn man so sehr leben
will wie du dann stirbt man auch nicht
ja also natürlich mitgedacht die
Einschränkung ist kann ein schlimmer
Unfall passieren oder was auch immer
aber wenn man so sehr leben will dann
stirbt man natürlich nicht und das
passiert dir dann auch nicht aber
umgekehrt Menschen die nicht mehr leben
wollen die sterben dann auch irgendwann
und das ist dann auch das ist die Gnade
von der du sprichst dass der Zustand der
dann noch ein guter Zustand ist weil man
es dann irgendwann auch möchte das
glaube ich schon aber es ist erst
interessant wie sozusagen am Anfang des
Lebens und auch am Ende des Lebens diese
großen existenziellen Fragen die bleiben
immer die gleichen ne und die sind da
klar beschäftigst du dich denn das Leben
ja ich meine das Leben hätte ja keine
keine Tiefe wenn es seine tragische
Dimension nicht hätte
also alle großen Dinge die dem
menschlichen Leben einen Wert verleihen
haben was tragisches das gilt natürlich
in erster Linie für den Tod und für die
Liebe
also dem Glück der Liebe steht ja immer
die Angst vor ihrem Ende oder ihrem
Scheitern oder sowas entgegen ne also
hier intensiver die Liebesgefühle sind
um umso größer
die Verlässlichkeit und die Tragik wenn
es zu Ende geht und so und das sind ja
so diese großen
evidenz-erfahrungen ja das menschliche
Lebens und der gehört nicht als zweites
eben der Tod dazu wenn diese Dinge nicht
da wären dann wäre das Leben eine ganz
merkwürdige Angelegenheit als drittes
könnte man vielleicht sogar noch den
Humor dazu ziehen ist richtig also der
das sollte Leben besser definitiv ja
würde ich auch sagen ja unbedingt ja ja
also du Humor ist eigentlich das was
einem am besten hilft mit der Tragik des
Lebens umzugehen
ne also ist in übel die trage ich Galgen
Humor den man hat oder über sich selber
lachen können die Fähigkeit zu haben aus
sich rauszutreten und sich selbst nicht
mehr so ernst zu nehmen
oder sich im Humor für nichts besonderes
zu halten also das sind ja ganz große
Fähigkeiten die der Mensch entwickelt
hat und die ihn vermutlich von anderen
Tieren unterscheidet
also wir wissen nicht ob es Tiere gibt
die ihn Sinn für das komische haben aber
mit Sicherheit nicht in dieser
ausgeprägten Form wie Menschen das haben
das ist übrigens ich habe ja vorhin von
bergsong erzählt ein großes Thema von
bergsong gewesen sich mit dem Humor und
mit dem Lachen und mit dem komischen und
so weiter zu beschäftigen
weil das eben doch etwas ist was die
Menschen in der gewissen Art und Weise
einzigartig macht und weil das eben eine
ganz große und ganz tolle
Kunstfertigkeit ist ne aus sich selbst
heraustreten zu können und er hat gesagt
in einer Welt in der alle Menschen durch
und durch rational wären würde immer
noch gelacht und zwar deswegen weil
lachen und und Humor und sowas etwas
sehr rationales ist weißt du dieses aus
sich heraustreten das ist gar nicht so
was rein intuitives oder so sondern das
ist Abstand zu sich selbst zu werden
und Abstand zu sich selbst zu empfehlen
und empfinden das ist eine ganz wichtige
Lebensqualität vielleicht hilft das
einem auch irgendwann am Lebensende mit
dem Tod besser umzugehen
wahrscheinlich ich kenne mich einen
interviewen von von Henning Mankel der
schwer im krebserkrankt war und der im
Angesicht des des Todes der wusste
irgendwann geht es zu Ende des war zwei
drei Jahre vor seinem Tod auf die Frage
bei Angst davor habe
genauso eine humorige Antwort gab und
sagte also ein bisschen schon aber wenn
wir mal ehrlich sind es ist bis jetzt
noch keiner leben da aus der Sache
herausgekommen ja und das fand ich halt
so ein schönen
Perspektive auf das Telefon von von
mankeln nur sein letztes Buch ich meine
das ist der Feind im Schatten wenn ich
das richtig in Erinnerung habe und da
hat er seine einsetzende Demenz
Wallander zum Thema gegeben das heißt
also was mich wahnsinnig beeindruckt hat
ist das ist da so eine mysteriöse Rätsel
Geschichte war übrigens wahnsinnig
modern vom Thema wahnsinnig modern da
ging es darum dass da ein U-Boot
irgendwo in der Ostsee aufgekreuzt ist
was da irgendwie nicht sein durfte aus
welchen Gründen auch immer und man
dachte die ganze Zeit russisches U-Boot
dann war es am Ende aber in
amerikanisches U-Boot was erst recht
nicht bekannt werden durfte und so
weiter aber der Fall selber wird nicht
geklärt
er wird also nur so am Rande und in
Teilen geklärt uns bleiben ganz viele
Details übrig und parallel dazu wird der
Kommissar war Landa immer dementer also
kriegt dann vergisst plötzlich Dinge hat
Erinnerungslücken und so weiter und man
kennt selber hatte ja glaube ich eine
leicht einsetzende Demenz ja kann sein
das heißt also jemand bei dem einen der
an sich selbst eine Demenz beobachtet ja
gestaltet in seinem letzten Roman einen
Kommissar der zunehmende Mensch wird und
deswegen entfallen nicht mehr
vollständig lösen kann
und ich glaube diese Souveränität mit
dem eigenen Schicksal umzugehen daraus
Kunst zu machen ähnlich wie beim Lachen
aus sich selbst herauszutreten ne und
sich was man ja macht wenn man Literatur
macht und sich selbst aus einer Distanz
zu beschreiben das ist ganz großes Kino
also mich hat dieses Buch sehr berührt
ich fand das ganz großartiger
psychologisch
super interessant ja hast du vor dem
Zustand recht hat Demenz ne also für
jemanden wie dich du der so sehr von
seinem Kopf lebt und von dem was er
denkt der so sehr ist was er denkt
was was würde das in dir machen mit dir
machen wenn du so eine Diagnose bekommen
würdest ja ich hoffe das Gute an der
Demenz ist dass man nicht merkt dass man
dem Moment ist sondern vergisst ich
glaube das ist eine lange das ist der
alte Weg dazu aber ich glaube die Phase
dahin ist so bitter ja nein ich glaube
das ist also ich ich denke das wird mir
passieren im Alter meinst du weil ja das
meine ich weil meine Großmutter ist 97
geworden und bei der ist das
Kurzzeitgedächtnis
kurzzeitig starke Kurzzeit Demenz
bekommen und ich glaube das ist
genetische meiner Familie vorgezeichnet
und ich glaube tatsächlich bin ganz
sicher so dass mir das passieren wird
ich verlasse mich ziemlich gut darauf
dass meine Langzeitgedächtnis was viel
besser ist als man kurzzeitig ist dass
das erhalten bleibt wieso so nüchtern
schaust du da drauf aber ich glaube ich
bin ja jetzt schon ich bin nicht kurz
seit dem Moment aber kurz Zeit
uninteressiert und zwar etwas zu viel
etwas zu viel wie du meinst das sind
schon diese Symptome weil das was sich
nicht interessiert da altert dein Gehirn
da bin ich ziemlich sicher also ich bin
gehöre auch zu den Menschen wo man sagt
was hast vor drei Tagen gegessen die
müssen da sehr lange drüber nachdenken
oder viele so Alltäglichkeiten ja wann
irgendwo der Zug fuhr und wann man wohin
musste und um wie viel Uhr die Aufnahme
zum Podcast beginnt und so das sind so
Dinge das kriege ich soeben noch hin
würde ich mal sagen ja aber da fällt
sozusagen keine keine große
Aufmerksamkeit drauf und diese Dinge die
Rauschen bei mir so richtig immer weg
und durch und ich denke dass ich das im
Alter verstärkt
also wenn ich mich in meinem Vater
unterhalte den interessiert das alles
überhaupt nicht mehr diese
kurzzeitsachen aber wenn der mein
philosophiegeschichtsbuchkorrektur liest
dann kann ich mich mit dem über Robert
Musil oder sie kriegen Krankenhaus
unterhalten als wäre er 40 so also das
überhaupt kein Alterungsprozess sichtbar
aber in anderen Bereichen ist ja
natürlich schon sichtbar also da wo der
Cursor der Aufmerksamkeit nicht mehr
liegt wenn man im Alter vor allen Dingen
in Erinnerungen lebt und einen das
alltägliche und tägliche immer banal
wird so dass man es nicht speichert
dann meine ich setzt rein psychologisch
so eine Art Kurt Kaisers ein ja also das
hängt ja auch damit zusammen die es gibt
ja so eine Sonne so eine weiße Schicht
eine Myelin die ist um deine deine
Nervenbahnen rum und sind die anfängt zu
verkrusten ja und porös und so zu werden
dann werden die Informationen nur noch
sehr langsam weitergegeben oder gar
nicht das spielt irgendwie auch eine
Rolle bei diesem ganzen riesigen Bereich
der Altersdemenz egal wie man das jetzt
nennt ob man da im Begriff Alzheimer
benutzen möchte oder nicht dass er alles
ein sehr umstrittenes Thema ja genau
aber ich denke das Teile des Gehirns
dieses systematisch nicht benutzt werden
irgendwie einen rosten also richtig
massiv sozusagen sichtbar in dieser
mühlenschicht sondern handelt und den
gingen auch und insofern bis zu einem
gewissen gerade ist einerseits Genetik
aber auf der anderen Seite spielt das
eigene Verhalten schon eine Rolle dabei
und ich glaube ich bin der klassische
Kandidat für eine kurzzeitig
gut dann werden wir uns irgendwo auf
eine auf eine Bank setzen gemeinsam mit
Hugo Egon Balder hat habe ich mal
gefragt wer sich das Altern vorstellt du
hast aber auch schöne Vorbilder Udo
Jürgens wo Egon baller sagt
Schröder unterschwelligible die
unterschätzen
absolut sehr sehr schöne Sache Hugo
sagte damals zu mir auf die Frage wie er
sich das Altern vorstellt sagt er weißt
du ich werde an der Nordsee auf einer
Bank sitzen und langsam verblöten und
ich die Vorstellung dass wir beide uns
einfach dazu setzen ja aber bei dir ist
das Langzeitgedächtnis weg und bei mir
das Kurzzeit
kannst du mal drüber nachdenken was
schlimmer ist ja also wenn du dich zwar
noch wunderbar daran erinnerst Du am
Morgen gegessen hast ja aber nicht mehr
so richtig weiß wer du bist
immer noch lieber kurz Zeit im Moment
als langzeitdem sowas von sowas den
großen Philosophen also auch bin ich nie
begegnet ne also ich habe ihn mal aus 10
Meter Entfernung gesehen aber nie mit
geredet und er wollte ich glaube es war
sein 75 geburtstag der hat das ZDF eine
große Show für ihn gemacht ja du weißt
wer die moderiert hat hast du die
moderiert ich meine ja dann sind wir
damals knapp aneinander vorbei ich weiß
nämlich nicht ich habe es nicht gesehen
aber es war ein Programmpunkt vorgesehen
dass er mit mir über die Liebe
philosophieren wollte ich hatte ja
damals
ein unordentliches Gefühl
geschrieben zu dem Buch was ich auch was
er mir geschickt hat
und indem er das meinte die unglaublich
Weise und so weiter dieses Buch sein und
das ist das alles genau so er würde das
über die Liebe genauso sehen wie ich
und die Kernthese dieses Buches ist dass
wir in der Liebe zwei Zustände
miteinander vermengen die relativ wenig
miteinander zu tun haben das eine ist
eben die Sexualität und die Hoffnung auf
größtmögliche Aufregung und auf der
anderen Seite der das Bedürfnis nach
Akzeptanz und Geborgenheit ja also
gepaart gerade mit der Minimum einer
Aufregung ja und dass das gleiche Chemie
also Stoffe sind wie Serotonin für die
Zufriedenheit und Dopamin für für die
Erledigung die nicht parallel
hochgehalten werden können das heißt du
kannst nicht in einem von einem anderen
Menschen dauerhaft geborgen elektrisiert
sein das geht das geht nur solange du
verknallt bist und der Zuschauer ist weg
ja nicht so oder meistens Luft deutlich
er so und das fand er alles stimmt alles
und die Widersprüchlichkeit der Liebe
und das Sexualität und
geborgenheitsbedürfnis aus verschiedenen
Wurzeln kommen auch evolutionär und so
das hat ihn alles überzeugt kurzer Rede
langer Sinn ja er wollte dass wir beide
auf Hannover sitzen und über die Liebe
philosophieren aber in weißen Bademäntel
UI ja das war also der Gag jetzt stelle
ich mir wirklich wo ich hätte das
gemacht diese Bilder wären mir eine
heute lang um die Ohren fliegen wie ich
ja schön gebräunt neben dem Leben so
gebeugten Udo Jürgens in Bademantel
sitze und über die Liebe Philosophie
schade dass du du hast abgesagt ja ich
habe gedacht ich bin Udo Jürgens
interessant ne ich mag den auch und ich
hätte gar nichts dagegen gehabt mich mit
ihm mal über die Liebe zu unterhalten
aber diese frotte Bademantel Nummer wäre
ich nie mehr los geworden
also ich hätte dir glaube
ich wirklich überhaupt nicht ausrechnen
was das mit mir gemacht hätte oder oder
auch einfach nur darunter nackt ja ja
das wäre wahrscheinlich die Bedingung
gewesen genau recht so wenig dahinter so
wenig darunter natürlich
der Mann mit dem Fagott ja das musst Du
kommen
der kann danach aber ist ein großartiges
Buch über die Geschichte der Familie von
Udo Jürgens eine wahnsinnsbruch
Bockelmann ja die in Moskau beginnt
Bankiers Familie und so weiter Wahnsinn
also ich habe ich habe das damals
verschlungen ist ein ganz großartiges
Buch der Mann mit dem Fagott ich habe
gerade Udo Jürgens gesagt fällt mir
jetzt gerade an Anstand und Moral und
all diese Dinge
ich ich höre immer noch gerne diese
Texte ehrenwertes Haus und so weiter
glaubst du mir das Menschen wenn du dich
jetzt auch mit der ganzen jüngeren
Philosophie Geschichte beschäftigt hast
Menschen die sozusagen ein sehr klaren
moralischen Kompass haben leben die
besser oder schlechter ich habe eine
Frage ja wenn ich das wüsste also das
hilft natürlich in vielen Situationen ne
aber so ein ganz klarer moralischer
Kompass den hat man ja eigentlich nur
wenn man stark e ideologische oder
starke religiöse Überzeugung hat wenn
man die nicht hat dann ist das mit dem
Kompass der immer richtig geht
eigentlich kaum möglich
ja stimmt ja also ich muss in vielen
Situationen wenn ich versuche die zu
bewerten immer wieder neu drüber
nachdenken ja weil ich wieder streitende
Gefühle habe oder war meine Gefühle
andere sind als meine Überlegungen sind
und muss versuchen das in Einklang zu
bringen das heißt also wenn man nicht so
eine so so ein religiöses oder
ideologisches Wertefundament hat dann
muss man sich in moralischer Hinsicht
wenn man Redlich sein will sich selbst
gegenüber eigentlich immer wieder neu
justieren
sind das dann ich habe neulich ein ein
wirklich gutes Interview mit Heinz Bude
gelesen den du auch kennst ja
ich schätze den sehr Du auch nehme ich
an ja ja absolut Heinz Bude ist ja sein
faszinierender Mensch ich habe den paar
mal getroffen für
dokumentations-projekte was damals als
wir 2017 diesen in Deutschland Film
gemacht haben und
das fand ich total interessant der
damals so ein paar kluge Sachen gesagt
hat damals auch erklärt woher zum
Beispiel die Wut vieler Einwanderer der
ersten Generation kommt auf Einwanderer
der letzten Generation ja auf die die
215 216 gekommen sind das das war damals
großes Thema und der sagte weißt du das
Gefühl dieser Leute ist und Sie werden
es sehen wenn sie ins Ruhrgebiet gehen
und so weiter weil bei ihnen gefragt
habe wie kann es sein dass ich auf
türkische Einwanderer der ersten
Generation treffe die glühen der
afd-anhänger waren das ist triffst du
dort und und er sagte ja ja ja das ist
doch logisch denken Sie mal darüber nach
und ja warum der meinte ja weil das
Gefühl ist pass auf wir sind jetzt hier
in dieses Land gekommen wir haben was
aufgebaut wir haben uns irrsinnig
angestrengt und jetzt kommt ihr und euch
wird einfach alles in den Schoß gelegt
aber das Gefühl ist hier stellt euch
jetzt bitte mal hinten an
weißt du wann welcher historischen
Situation mir dass du zum ersten Mal
aufgefallen ist nach der Mauerfall ja
total Berlin
Begrüßungsgeld und
also da gab es tatsächlich und auch als
dann die Migrationswellen aus Osteuropa
kamen genau das war ja dann in den 90er
Jahren ein Thema das viele Leute aus
Polen und so weiter gekommen sind und so
weiter und was haben die Türken
geschimpft richtig ja aber irgendwie
liebt man es so weil es ist alles so es
ist alles so menschlich und es ist alles
irgendwie so leicht nachvollziehbar
meine Ballade deine Banane es ist es ist
kein ich bin z.B immer noch aber ganz
neulich mit Freunden darüber gesprochen
ich kann mir irgendwann Anfang der 90er
dieses Land
und zur Begrüßung gab es bei mir keine
Begrüßungsgeld und auch keine Bananen
sondern mir würde zu Begrüßung direkt
mal mal italienischer
Motorradführerschein abgenommen und zwar
wieder zweifelhaften Begründung sie
haben ein Italien im
Motorradführerschein gemacht sie können
ja gar nicht richtig Motorradfahren ich
hatte noch nie verstehen
Selbstwertgefühl nach die besten ja
Autofahrer Motorradfahrer der Welt
endlich sieht's einer ja und ich bis
heute und das ist jetzt wirklich 30
Jahre her bis heute regt mich das
unfassbar auf und ich habe ihn noch nie
wieder bekommen ich müsste jetzt wieder
ganz neuen Motorradführerschein machen
dabei habe ich doch noch in irgendeinem
safe oder so die müsstest
werde ja so machen wir jetzt mal ganz
offiziell lieber pass auf wir kommen vom
Thema Heinz Bude hat neulich darüber
nachgedacht was so ein altmodischer
Begriff wie Sünde ja was was der für wir
leben heute noch bedeutet und das fand
ich total interessant er sagte Sünde ist
ein immer noch eine ganz wichtige
Kategorie und zwar mit der Begründung
wenn ich keine Idee von meiner
sündenfähigkeit habe so hat er sie
ausgedrückt ja dann habe ich auch keine
Idee des Scheiterns an mir selbst ja das
heißt dann weiß ich umgekehrt auch nicht
was ein gutes was ein gelungenes Leben
sein könnte und er sagt die Idee und das
fand ich so interessant die Idee der
Sünde ist ja ein Vergehen an dir selbst
und an deinen eigenen Vorstellungen ja
von dem wie ein richtiges und wie ein
gutes Leben aussehen könnte ja also das
heißt man versöhnlich dich sozusagen an
seinen eigenen Prinzipien geht gar nicht
so sehr um die anderen
ja das ist ein interessanter Gedanke
also kann hat versucht mit seinem
kategorischen Imperativ die Kategorie
der Sünde der Kirche wegzunehmen und die
als Selbstverpflichtung sich selbst
gegenüber zu retten also dieser gleiche
Gedanke dass man einem gewissen
gegenüber verpflichtet ist und wenn man
den religiösen Kontext herausnimmt dass
man dafür in die Hölle kommt oder
bestraft wird dann ist es immer noch es
sozusagen das größtmögliche Unrecht was
man sich selbst zufügen kann ist wenn
man gegen seine eigene Grundsätze
verstößt
also ich meine eigentlich ist das
Gewissen was man hat es ja so eine Art
Uhr die eigentlich immer richtig geht ja
nur man selber und guckt nicht immer
gerne so genau drauf
man merkt ja wenn man Dinge macht die
moralisch nicht in Ordnung genau also
ich nehme an jeder Mensch merkt das
außer er hat schon tausende von malen
oder so gemacht also ich glaube
irgendwie gibt es irgendwann so ein
Effekt dass das irgendwann so zum
Verstummen gebracht wird und dann geht's
vielleicht auf dem Totenbett erst wieder
los oder so aber normalerweise ist ja ja
ist ein bewusst wenn man an sich selbst
versündigt glücklich wäre es schon das
Langzeitgedächtnis verloren hat in dem
Moment das stimmt das stimmt sogar
den Trick des das beichtens riecht und
dass der große Unterschied kann der ja
in der protestantischen Tradition steht
also dass du dir selbst gegenüber
verpflichtet bist und nicht gegen dein
Gewissen Handel darfst da gibt es ja
kein verzeihen in dem Spiel anders als
in der katholischen Kirche wo man sich
ja von allem befreien kann ja jetzt kann
man sich die Frage stellen was ist
besser ne also die protestantische
Tradition dass der Schuldenberg ja den
du anhäufst in deinem Leben immer größer
ja und so laufen die Leute dann noch
irgendwann so ganz Leben
mit der Sünde ist natürlich auch ein
Krieg irgendwo hingehen Vater oder
Rosenkränze und alles ist wieder gut ist
so viel muss es nicht sein kommt zehn
aber Maria reicht bitte das heißt
wahrscheinlich keine richtig großen
Sünden was wäre denn wenn du jetzt ganz
als Kind oder Jugendlicher richtig
schwere Sünden zu beichten gehabt
hättest hätten die dich da auch so mit
zehn Vater Unser davon kommen lassen
ich ehrlich gesagt wir haben als Kinder
ja immer alle Sünden irgendwie
zusammengekratzt und überhaupt auf
irgendwie einen eine
Nennenswertes sündenkonto zu kommen und
dann setzte man sich da rein irgendwie
und hat das dann ganz schnell so runter
und als man dann so ein bisschen
älter wurde kam dann eine neue Kategorie
dazu dann nuschelte man ganz ganz zum
Schluss und so ganz verstehen so
und das war in der Hoffnung der der
Priester der auf der anderen Seite sitzt
hat das gar nicht richtig gehört und gar
nicht richtig verstanden ich denke
bestimmten Alter kannst du auch jemanden
der gerade darauf gewartet hat nein nein
nein ich muss die da immer ein Schutz
nehmen ich habe all das wirklich in der
Kirche und ich hatte chemikirche zu tun
mit Priestern zu tun nie erlebt
glücklicherweise nie nie erlebt und ich
ich
das sind ganz fürchterliche Sachen die
da immer wieder auch jetzt gerade wieder
rauskommen aber Richard jetzt zum
Schluss eine Sache noch ich ich wir
haben uns jetzt einfach so treiben
lassen ich fand es herrlich mit dir mal
so über das Leben zu sprechen wann kommt
dein Band dann dann fährt er Philosoph
im Oktober okay dann reden wir noch mal
ein bisschen ausführlicher darüber finde
ich gut ich habe noch eine persönliche
Frage die ich ja zum Schluss wir reden
gerade sozusagen über Gelassenheit und
was man gewinnt wenn man älter wird und
und das Leben und den Sinn und die
Parkbank an der Nordsee auf der wieder
mit Hugo Egon weil da sitzen werden dem
dem dem Gott der Gott der der Früchte
der Zitrone und der Himbeere und der
Erde hast du das geguckt
regelmäßig aber ich wusste wovon die
Rede ist
das musste man auch nicht mehr als
einmal sehen wenn man den zweiten Mal
stellte man fest dass man die
schwierigen dieses komischen Spiels
sowieso nicht versteht und zweitens das
ist irgendwie immer dasselbe ist was da
abläuft richtig also die hätten
eigentlich eine Folge jede Woche
ausstrahlen können ja ist da gab es also
überhaupt keine inhaltliche Variationen
oder irgendwie sowas
total ich habe oft gedacht ich habe Hugo
so auf der lebt auch so ein herrlicher
Lebenskünstler Hugo Egon weil das ein
wirklich ein großartiger Typ und ich ich
habe Hungers darf ich jetzt einmal
erzählen aus dem Nähkästchen geplaudert
das war die Zeit in der wir noch in Köln
lebten und ich bin immer für die
Produktion nach Hamburg hin und her
geflogen und komme eines Morgens
irgendwie so ein Donnerstag morgen zum
Hamburger Flughafen und da stehen diese
ganzen
graugewandelten Menschen mit ihren
Aktenkoffern ja und alle bin müde und
kaputt und müssen jetzt halt irgendwie
ihr Tagwerk wieder beginnen und diesen
dieses Flugzeug rein und ich gucke mich
so um in dieser Abflughalle und ganz
hinten in der Ecke steht ein Typ mit
einer Sonnenbrille obwohl es draußen
düster dunkel Hamburg Regen war dunkle
Sonnenbrille und eine
kanarienvogel-gelbe Lederjacke
der fiel auf kannst du dir vorstellen
und es war unverkennbar Hugo Egon Balder
und ich gehe zu ihm hin und sag Hugo
schön dich zu sehen und der guckt so
hoch und sagt ach mensch Markus du bist
und dann sage ich Hugo wieso diese
Sonnenbrille und er tue ich möchte nicht
erkannt werden
wahrscheinlich der gleiche Grund warum
Heino Zeit seines Lebens oder
Sonnenbrille getragen
also wenn du nicht gesehen werden
möchtest du nicht deine Kanarienvogel
gelbe Lederjacke natürlich ich hatte
immer das Gefühl weil da ist ein
entfernter Verwandter von Rolf Zacher
ja also die haben wir beide sowas
grundannarchisch ist und die Vorstellung
mit ihm gemeinsam auf der Nordsee Bank
zu verzaubern bis jetzt nicht die
übelste Vorstellung nicht die übelste
gar nicht gar nicht na dann hugo ist
dann ein Lebenskünstler wirklich Richard
ich danke Dir sehr ich danke dir auch
Markus das war sehr inspirierend ein
kleiner ein kleiner Streifzug durch die
Gegenwart leben genau bis bald danke dir
mach's gut tschüss Ciao
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]